my friend
she gets me cookies this is my second
mom in new york it's a popular jewelry
yes it is
[Music]
i make charm for beyonce i make 10
pieces for her and i make a special
charm for 30 rocks
[Music]
[Applause]
every night i like to watch asap rocky
music radio because i like to watch my
merchandise my name is eva sam my
husband say your name is asap eva
[Music]
at this point you may be wondering who
though is asap eva and where is the
story going hell you might even be
asking yourself what is this story all
about
fair enough let's start at the beginning
eva and her family immigrated to new
york from macau in 1982. getting into
the jewelry business was a no-brainer
for eva she comes from a long line of
jewelers we opened popular jewelry in
1988 october 3rd in new york in the
beginning it's difficult
then one day the rap god smiled down on
her and sent in capitano wu-tang clan
he's the first rapper to come to our
store after that he sent all the people
and we start to have a lot of famous
people come
[Music]
charlie scott jaden smith joey badass
golling young paris wi-fi funeral
nakamura famous people come because we
do everything on time make a good job
for them very quick and have a big
selection
we have 24 karat gold platinum diamond
ruby ammo we have silver we have
everything and have a good personality
i don't treat them like a customer i
treat them like my own kids today was a
good day
okay
[Music]
family and jewelry are synonymous to eva
in fact the day after her son was born
she went straight back to work i would
not quit the job
i'm here every single day
popular jewelry is more than the sum of
its glittery parts it's a family it's a
home and eva is the my customer call me
gold mother i have a lot to nickname
what they give me
that's really sweet
[Music]
you